RUCHIKA: Right.
We'll go ahead and get
started with the talk today.
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Ruchika.
I work in the people
development department
within People
Operations, particularly
focusing on well-being
learning for Googlers.
I have helped
co-found G+ Program.
And I also teach
Search Inside Yourself.
Our team also brings
other programs
like Managing Your Energy.
We're working on an online
version of Good Stress/Bad
Stress program that will be
brought to you very soon.
I'm really passionate about
mindfulness as a vehicle for me
to have sanity in my work
life and in my personal life.
I started these practices
about eight years ago.
And they have been
profoundly helpful
in all kinds of difficult
situations in my life.
My journey started with Search
Inside Yourself program here.
And I've done some
work outside, as well.
But as a parent, I
find so many moments
where just being
present and aware
in times of difficulty
when our children are sick,
they're having a tantrum.
I have an 11-year-old
daughter, a middle schooler,
and a one-year-old son.
And I have a lot of
moments where I just
don't know how I can be helpful
in that particular situation.
So staying mindful
and present and open
to whatever is
happening in that moment
has been tremendously helpful.
So to support that and share it
with all of you as part of G+,
we are trying to integrate
mindful parenting program
at Google where we will
bring speakers at least once
a quarter, if not more,
to talk about this topic
and potentially also
offer some classes,
or give you resources that you
can avail outside of Google.
So with that
introduction, I'm really
excited to have
Isa Gucciardi here
to talk to us about
conscious parenting today.
She describes this
talk as, let's face it.
Parenting is hard.
We agree.
Most of us become parents
with very little idea
about what will be
asked of us, and what we
will need to ask of ourselves.
In order to offer our
children as many opportunities
to be successful in
navigating the complexities
of modern life, we have to
gain great awareness of how we
can best meet those challenges.
In this talk, Isa Gucciardi
covers important topics
to help parents meet their
children with as much
love, discernment, and
capacity as possible,
while offering
strategies to help
parents gain greater
confidence and enjoyment
raising their children.
So Isa holds a degree
and certificates
in psychology, cultural and
linguistic anthropology,
comparative religion,
hypnotherapy,
and transformational healing.
She's the creator of highly
effective therapeutic model
called Depth Hypnosis.
And she's also the author of
"Return to the Great Mother,"
a book that she's gifted
to me this morning.
And I'm eager to read that.
It's a book on birthing.
Isa is the founding director
of the Foundation of the Sacred
Stream, and teaches nationally
and internationally.
She has two children.
so she's been there.
It's not all abstract.
I'm sure she'll share some of
her own experiences with us
as well.
And an active counseling
practice in San Francisco
where she resides
with her partner.
Please join me in
welcoming Isa, who
will take us through
this one-hour journey
on conscious parenting together.
[APPLAUSE]
ISA GUCCIARDI:
Thank you, Ruchika.
Thank you so much.
Just a moment to thank
Ruchika for all the work
that she has done
in carrying forward
the legacy of [INAUDIBLE]
and your own inspiration
to benefit the Google community.
And I've actually
had the good fortune
to join you here a couple
of times over the last year.
In May I was here
with Thupten Jinpa,
who is His Holiness, the Dalai
Lama's main English language
interpreter.
And he was here
speaking on his new book
called "A Fearless Heart,"
which is an amazing book.
If you're looking for tools
to become more conscious,
try that book.
And if you didn't get to see
his talk when he was here,
I think it's on YouTube.
And you can benefit
from seeing that.
And it was actually on
[INAUDIBLE] last day
last fall that I accompanied
Robert Thurman, who
came to speak to
the Google community
about spirituality
and the workplace.
And again, he's another
wonderful teacher
if you're looking for
resources to become more aware.
His book, "Infinite
Life," really
focuses on qualities that can
help you as you're parenting.
So over the last
year I've also gotten
to know Ruchika a
little bit better.
And one of the
things that I've seen
is that we really
share a common vision.
And that vision is to try to
bring as much mindfulness,
as much awareness, as
much consciousness,
to as many people as possible.
So it's such a
privilege to be here,
to be able to share
that vision, and to be
able to speak to you on the
topic of conscious parenting.
As Ruchika said, I'm the
parent of two children.
And I've been
counseling and teaching
families and children,
teens, couples,
over the last 20 years.
And over the course
of the last 10 years,
I've noticed a big shift
in the central issues
around parenting.
And that shift is due mainly
to the more central role
that technology is now
playing in the family.
And I think this is one
of the big, big challenges
that parents are
trying to work with.
And the challenges that parents
face today in raising children
are really, really different
than the challenges
that their parents faced.
Not only do parents
have to figure out
how to do with less
sleep, but they also
have to determine the role
they want technology to play
in their child's development.
If parents find
themselves with less time
than they would like
to devote to parenting,
they have to figure out new
strategies for discipline,
nourishment, and enrichment.
And this is
difficult when people
find themselves trying
to navigate the issues
around work/life balance.
Many times people
have to face down
issues of self-doubt
and guilt in trying
to make the choices
that they want
to make for the best and
highest good for their children.
So one of the first
steps that parents
must take toward
meeting these challenges
and learning to parent
more consciously
is to develop a
good understanding
of their own values.
If parents want to be
able to raise children
who can meet the
challenges of the future
with an open heart
and a focused mind,
they must not only
understand, but be
able to clearly
communicate their values
to their children in everything
they do and in everything they
say.
So in order to be able to
communicate values clearly
and to apply them
in a consistent way,
parents must spend some time
learning what their values are.
This may sound simple.
But it's surprising to see
how many people struggle
to articulate their
values for themselves,
and much less for
their children.
The effort to engage
in this articulation
is very important, perhaps one
of the most important steps
that parents must take
in order to parent
with more mindfulness
and more awareness.
Because parenting
is taking place now
in such a different environment,
role models and mentors
are difficult to come by.
This compounds an
already age-old problem,
which is that many of us were
parented by people who weren't
parented well themselves.
So we have this legacy of less
than ideal situations leading
into parenting.
So many parents just
don't have the role models
they need readily
at hand when they're
trying to make decisions
about screen time,
toilet training,
internet privacy,
curfews, it's all together.
And it's important
therefore to seek
role models who hold the
values that you hold,
and seek their help.
In order to do this, you have
to define your own values.
What is important to you?
Do you know how to
begin to answer this?
Do you have a clear
idea of what values
you want your children to
bring forward into the world
as they mature and take
their place in confronting
the complexities of
the modern world?
Let's start at a fairly high
level here looking at values.
So I'd like you to
just take a moment
and focus inward
and allow yourself
to consider two spiritual values
that are important to you.
So just let yourself
think for a moment.
What are two spiritual values
that are important to you?
And if you're
co-parenting, what are
two spiritual values you know to
be of value to your co-parent?
If there are differences
in your sets of values,
what is your strategy for
bridging those differences
so you can present a unified
message to your children?
If your values are
similar, what kinds
of activities and
interactions do you
create on a regular basis
to communicate those values
to your children?
Given the importance
of these values,
whom do you have to turn
to, to help you continue
to address and develop
these values in parenting
your children?
You can see how much goes into
the development of just one
set of values.
But there are many other
values to look at in order
to be able to parent with as
much mindfulness, awareness,
and consciousness as possible.
As I was putting my thoughts
together to talk to you,
I thought I was going to
touch more fully on the issues
that we touch on in
the conscious parenting
classes at the Sacred Stream
Center in Berkeley, California.
These classes focus on helping
parents locate inner resources,
and learning how to
draw upon them better.
They focus on helping parents
articulate their needs
and values.
And they help parents learn
how to work effectively
with willfulness, and focus on
discipline more effectively.
And they offer
parents strategies
for parenting a child
who is challenged.
The reason for
examining these issues
in the context of conscious
parenting is simple.
When these issues are addressed,
the protection and cultivation
of the child's authentic
expression in the world
is assured.
And if you were to ask me
to define one goal that we
as parents must do
our best to attain,
I would say that it is
this-- the protection
and cultivation of our
child's authentic expression
in the world.
So that is the topic I would
like to focus on here today.
Whenever I'm working
with families,
especially the parents
of young children,
I always try to walk a line
between creating a forum where
people can understand
themselves more fully
so that they can understand how
many resources they actually
have, and offering advice
or council from that place,
and the line between
offering opinion.
It's really easy for me to go
into opinion about parenting.
But I'm really going
to try not to do that.
But I might.
I might wander into
the opinion place,
because this is really
so close to my heart--
this idea of being able
to protect your child's
expression in the world.
This is so important.
Many great educators,
including Maria Montessori
and Rudolf Steiner,
spoke to this issue, each
in their own way.
They each offered structures
that support children
and having the
freedom to discover
their own unique talents,
gifts, and capacities.
And they also offer structures
to address areas of weaknesses
or obstacles that children may
have which affect their ability
to fully move into the world
with those native gifts.
The reason that the discussion
around values is so important
is because it is values that
become the structures we
offer our children
within which they
learn to express themselves.
I'm gonna say that again,
because it sounds complicated,
but not-- can't get there.
I'm gonna do it again.
The reason that the discussion
around values is so important
is that values
become the structures
we offer our children
within which they
learn to express themselves.
If we do not have clarity
around our own values,
we cannot offer effective
structures to our children.
And worse, if we have
no values, or values
that actually inhibit
the authentic expression
of the child, children spend
important developmental time
trying to adapt themselves
to values which have nothing
to do with their
authentic expression,
and which in fact may impede it.
How many of you have spent
time trying to navigate around
a parent with anger issues?
Or addiction issues?
What did that do to your
ability to know what calls
to you from your own heart?
It is, I believe,
important to consider
that our most important
task as parents
is to try to develop a family
system whose structures support
the authentic expression
of the highest
potential of our children,
to help them learn
how to listen to what is calling
to them in their own hearts.
This may sound easy.
But it's not.
When some people hear
this, they think, OK.
Anything goes.
Let the kids do
whatever they want.
As long as they're expressing,
it's going to be OK.
Or other parents may
hear this and think, OK.
I have to figure out what my
child's highest potential is
and steer that child
toward them at every turn.
Other parents may
respond, they're my kids.
They're going to do what I
want, not what they want.
But the task at hand is
more nuanced than any
of these approaches.
First of all, we
need to define what
we mean by a child's
highest potential, which
I am using interchangeably
here with the child's deepest
calling, the child's most
authentic expression,
the child's gifts.
I'm using these terms
interchangeably,
because they each offer a
different view and definition
that point to the
complexity of the deepest
aspects of our children.
Naturally, every child's
highest potential
has its own expression.
Every child has a
set of gifts that she
brings into the world that
resonate with her highest
calling.
We must at once try
to tune ourselves
to this deepest aspect
of our children,
understand its
requirements, and get out
of the way of impeding
its expression,
while at the same time creating
structures which support it.
This may sound like
rubbing your belly
and tapping your head
at the same time.
And indeed, it is.
But it is something we
can learn how to do.
So I would like to identify
some of these tasks that will
help you with this process.
First individually,
and then show you
how to put them together so
that the tapping and the rubbing
seems intuitive and easy.
These tasks center
around a set of questions
I would like to offer you.
First, how do I recognize
my child's deepest calling?
Two, how do I recognize
my child's gifts?
Three, why do I have to get out
of the way of the expression
of my child's potential?
Four, how do I get
out of the way?
Five, what does
it mean to create
structures that support the
expression of my child's
potential?
So we're going to address each
one of these individually.
The first question is, how do
I recognize my child's deepest
calling?
This is actually
surprisingly easy to do.
It is really just a
matter of watching
what your child is drawn to.
Your children will naturally be
drawn to their highest calling
if they are not interrupted.
How do I recognize
my child's gifts?
The answer is the same.
Watch what your
child is drawn to.
But recognizing the child's
gifts goes one step further.
This involves watching what
games the child creates,
what stories the child
tells, and the way the child
seeks to express herself.
There is an important part to
cultivating a child's gifts
that has to do with the
filtering of the kind
of information
that the child uses
as raw material for
that expression.
And I will speak to
that in just a moment.
The next question
is, why do I have
to get out of the way of
the expression of my child's
potential?
We tend to think of
our children as ours.
But they actually
belong to themselves.
If they are lucky, their
path through this life
is a long one that extends
far beyond the few years
that we care for them.
It is important to consider that
your ideas about what you want
for your child beyond wanting
them to be happy and safe
might become interrupting
to their natural expression.
How many of you wanted
to study music, but were
told by your parents you had
to go to business school?
What message did this give
you about the possibility
of being supported in the
world by your deepest calling?
How does this affect you
on a daily basis today?
With this information,
consider how important
it is to give your child the
message that he can trust
his deepest calling, and that
he will be able to find a way
to let that expression of
that calling-- whatever
that expression
is-- support him.
Give him practice in
letting all the potential
that the calling
and that calling
express itself by
supporting what he loves.
And step out of the way.
Next question is, how
do I get out of the way?
Well, I've got a long
answer to this question.
So bear with me.
One of the best ways
to get out of the way
is to look at your
attachments to your children
being a particular way.
Those attachments are probably
a function of something
that did not work in
your own childhood.
For instance, let's say
you grew up in a household
without a mother present.
And you felt her absence keenly.
You grow, you marry a woman,
and you have children.
And then you realize this
woman is more problematic
than I thought.
This is not the person I
thought I was marrying.
But now you have children.
And because you
know how hard it was
for you not to
have a mother, you
put up with all kinds of bad
behavior from your spouse
or from the child's mother,
rather than take the child
and leave the situation
and take the risk
that the child may grow up
without a full-time mother
figure.
If you were not so
attached to your child
having a mother
because of the pain
that you experienced
at not having a mother,
you might have more
clarity in responding
to your spouse's bad behavior.
Who knows?
Not having this problematic
woman in your child's life
on such a consistent
basis might be
the best thing for your child.
But you cannot see this,
or even consider it
because of the unaddressed
issues that you carry from
your own wounding
at being motherless.
In many ways, when we talk
about conscious parenting,
we are talking about becoming
more conscious of ourselves.
We are talking
about understanding
what motivates us before we
even approach our children.
The examination
of our motivation
and the way that it
drives decision-making
is a good example
of one of the steps
in the process of becoming
a more aware parent.
Again, one of the best
ways to get out of the way
is to stop risking
interrupting your child's
authentic expression,
and to look deeply
at your own experience
of being parented.
Seek to understand the
aspects of your upbringing
that worked best for you and
your own self-expression.
And ask how you can apply
that understanding to serving
your child's expression.
In this way you can tap
into your own resources
and become your own mentor.
You can also look at the
aspects of your upbringing
that did not work
for you, and get help
in changing the way that these
aspects of your childhood
affect you today.
I remember when
I first found out
I was pregnant with
my first child.
I was looking at the
pregnancy indicator.
And it was like it was yes.
And I'm like, oh!
And I literally with the
indicator still in my hand,
I ran to the phone.
We made phone calls back then.
I ran to the phone and
I called a therapist.
And I literally had the receiver
for the phone and the pregnancy
kit indicator in
my hand, because I
knew there was no
way I was going
to be able to face the
challenges of mothering
with all of my own
childhood experience
affecting me in
an uninformed way.
I mean, I didn't
know much back then.
But I knew that, right?
So not only do you have
to get out of the way
by addressing your own
unexamined experience in order
to be as clear as possible about
how to support your child's
potential, but it is
also important to look
at the experience that the child
is exposed to in the larger
cultural context.
With the newfound
clarity gained in looking
at your personal issues,
you can determine
if the experience of the
larger cultural environment
is supporting your
child's potential or not.
And this is where
that raw material
the child uses to formulate
her expression that I just
spoke about comes in.
And it is also where
the issue of values
comes into play in
a very powerful way.
You have to understand
what you value
and what you don't value in
the larger cultural context.
How do you feel
about screen time
versus personal engagement?
Something to think
about for a minute.
What role should technology play
in early childhood development?
What level of violence
in computer games
is acceptable to you?
How do you feel about letting
children play with toy guns?
The answer to these questions
will determine the answer
to the last question for you.
What does it mean
to create structures
that support the expression
of my child's potential?
The choices that you
make around values
create the structures
that support
your child's development.
If you have no
defined value system,
the values of the
larger cultural context
will become the structure
that supports or impedes
your child's expression.
If your values are based
on an unexamined response
to the way you
were parented, they
will become the
structures that support
or impede the expression of
your child's authentic self.
Is this what you
want for your child?
If the answer is no,
you already understand
why conscious parenting
is so important.
If you enter into
parenting without being
aware of the values
that are driving
your decisions
around parenting, you
will not know how to define
or articulate your values.
If you don't have clear values,
you cannot know how to create
structures that support
you in skillfully guiding
the manifestation of your
child's highest potential.
So as you get ready to
practice rubbing your belly
and tapping your
head at the same time
as you step into becoming
a more conscious parent,
just remember--
all you have to do
is observe carefully what
your child is drawn to.
What stories is he telling you?
How does she express herself?
Invest time in looking
at your own experience
of being parented.
And see what worked for
you and what did not.
Take time to understand
the extent to which you
want the larger cultural
context to participate
in the formation of your child.
If you follow these
steps, you will
know how to create experiences
which provide enough structure
to nurture your
child's potential,
but not so much
structure that it
stifles the expression
of your child's
heart's deepest calling.
See.
No so hard.
Conscious parenting may not
be as hard as you thought.
In these times when we are
facing societal upheaval,
environmental destruction,
and so much uncertainty
about the prospect that
technology has for delivering
us from an increasingly
unstable future,
I believe it is our
responsibility as parents
to do our best to raise
children who as adults meet
the challenges of the
future with an open heart
and a focused mind.
It will be much easier
for them to do this
and to attain this
level of clarity
if they can listen to
their heart's calling.
If they know what
their gifts are,
and if they can trust the
expression of their highest
potential, and know how
it will support them,
not only themselves,
but those around them.
So if you'd like to explore
these matters in more depth
and gain more insight in how to
parent more consciously, please
join us at the Sacred
Stream Center in Berkeley.
Weekly classes are
starting March 2.
And if you're interested in
our offering those classes
in this context here to
the Google community,
just let Ruchika know.
But for now I ask you to
bring forward some questions.
I love questions, even questions
on things we haven't covered,
because there's so
much to parenting
that it's hard to cover
it in a short talk.
So please.
Anybody have a question?
You had a question, right?
Ruchika, did you want
to say something?
RUCHIKA: I'm going
to pass on the mic.
ISA GUCCIARDI: Oh, OK.
RUCHIKA: I put it under here.
There it is.
ISA GUCCIARDI: You
had a question, right?
He had a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Phillip.
Thanks for being here.
My question is, the
things you talk about, do
you have any data of how
much it actually matters,
as in give child a good
environment to grow up in.
But all these micromanagerial
type of things.
Do they actually matter?
Like if we obstruct the child's
expression of their talents,
aren't they going
to end up actually
doing what they want anyways?
I mean, how much real direction
control do we have as parents?
Like, this is all something
we might choose to do.
But in retrospect,
does it really matter?
ISA GUCCIARDI: Well,
you know, if you're
going to speak at that
level, then you're saying,
well, the child has
their own destiny.
They have their own fate.
It doesn't matter what we do
because they're following it.
Is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: I'm not a
proponent of fate.
I'm just asking about the data.
ISA GUCCIARDI: I think
that it's difficult
when you're dealing with
issues of expression,
of the ineffable.
It's hard to have hard
data that supports
or that denies the efficacy
or the authenticity
of that expression,
because we are really far
into the ineffable when
we think about what
is it that impels us
into the world, what
is it that draws us.
And I spend most days
working with people
who have been really badly
wounded in their childhood,
where they've had-- I mean,
sometimes I joke around
and I say, all you
have to do these days
in order to be
wounded is be born.
It's so hard to be in
the world right now.
But one of the things
that I see again
and again every day,
I mean 10 hours a day,
is that people who have
been hurt or interrupted
in being able to
rest in themselves
have serious problems
later in life.
And those problems can range
from anxiety, depression.
I mean, look at the number
of people-- you want data?
Look at the number of people
who are on antidepressants.
What is it?
Like 20 million?
I mean, sometimes I'm
in a grocery store
and I look around.
And I realize I'm
the only person
in this place that is
not altered-- either
on prescription drugs or on
pot or on alcohol or on heroin
or on ice.
It's like, everybody is trying
to get away from themselves.
And the reason they're trying
to get away from themselves
is because they
weren't parented well.
People who can
rest in themselves,
people who know
themselves, people
who understand what's
important for them
and want to express that
importance and trust that they
can express that importance,
don't need drugs.
So I don't know if that
answers your question.
But hopefully I got
somewhere near there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ISA GUCCIARDI: Mm hm.
AUDIENCE: As I've
been trying to become
more mindful in my
own practice and not
trigger as quickly, you know,
be more detached and everything.
One of the places I've
found it hardest to do that
is in parenting.
I have an almost
five-year-old girl and a one
and one half-year-old boy.
And one of the
things I've noticed
is obviously kids
trigger you a lot.
Right?
They're sort of
almost programmed to.
But I've also found I try
to sometimes be detached
and say, let's do this thing.
Let's do this thing.
But oftentimes being a little
bit more forceful in terms
of getting a little bit
angry or showing a little bit
of disappointment or even
being a little bit stronger,
it compels them in a way
then just sort of saying,
let's not make a mess, let's
not make a mess over and over
doesn't.
And so I struggle with that
because on the one hand,
I don't want to just be reacting
from my amygdala to my kids.
I want to be compassionate
and so forth.
But kids often do seem to
respond more to a little bit
more forceful response.
I'm just curious how you think
about resolving that paradox.
How to remain mindful, but still
be compelling to your kids.
ISA GUCCIARDI: I
don't think there's
any contradiction
between mindfulness
and being compelling.
I think that this is
important for your children
to understand that
there are structures.
And you play a little bit.
OK, let's put it all away.
Here we are.
Sing a song.
Put it away.
And then they start
punching each other.
It's like, OK.
We're not playing anymore.
We're putting things away.
And you can have that
kind of compelling quality
in your voice.
But you need to
strip out the anger.
And that's what the mindfulness
practice helps with.
But I don't think it's a problem
giving very clear, compelling
statements to your children.
I think it's important.
They need that.
AUDIENCE: If you're firm,
even in a detached way,
that works as well as--
ISA GUCCIARDI: It works better.
It works better.
If you've got anger
issues coming up,
it probably doesn't
have anything
to do with the child
doing what they're doing.
So one of the great
things about parenting
is that it's a workshop to show
you the places within yourself
that you haven't addressed yet.
And that's why you're saying
like they kind of go for it.
They do kind of go for it.
They want to push.
They want to know how big
a container do I have here?
You know, how much can I
trust you to support me
without getting off balance?
And what happens
when I push you?
I mean, those are important
questions for children
to know the answer to.
And what's really
important to do
is to give them a clear answer.
You can push me this far.
But you can't push
me any further.
And if you push me any further,
I'm not going to get angry.
I'm not going to reject you.
But you are going to
have some consequences.
And we're going to
apply those consequences
in a consistent and clear way.
And I think that--
AUDIENCE: And that's the
structure you're talking about.
ISA GUCCIARDI: That's the
structure we're talking about.
Exactly.
And you know, if you
address your anger issues,
then you've got a structure.
If you don't address
your anger issues,
you don't have a structure.
Or the kids are like, I
don't know what to do.
And then they pull back.
They hold back.
They're thinking about
what am I going to do
and how is it going
to affect you,
rather than what
am I going to do
and how is that
going to affect me.
You don't want to have
children in that position.
They want to know.
They need to know what's going
to happen at any given time,
in general.
I mean, of course,
things can happen
that are outside the box.
But they generally need
to have consistency.
And I think it's a
big mistake-- a lot
of times in
spiritual communities
there's this idea that you're
not allowed to be angry,
or that you shouldn't
listen to your anger,
or you should
overcome your anger.
I actually think anger
tells us important things.
And I think that you can't just
be unleashing your anger all
the time and say, oh, I
have my right to my anger.
But if you are
getting angry, it may
be because your
boundary's being violated.
Or your child may
be getting angry
because her boundaries
are being violated.
And that needs to
be listened to.
And you don't want to give
her the same instruction
that you give yourself.
I have to overcome my anger.
I can't be angry.
And she's got somebody who's
taking her books at school all
the time.
And she's angry.
Good.
She should be angry.
Right?
It's not like, OK.
Let's think about forgiveness.
No.
Let's think about
why are you angry.
You're angry because
you're being violated.
How are you being violated?
How do you deal
with that violation?
What is the most useful
way in approaching,
working with that violation,
other than your anger?
But listen to the anger.
Right?
So I could give that
same advice to you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
How useful would it
be if in addition
to listening to their
child's calling and interests
and providing that
environment for them
to fulfill that
potential, you also
introduce a more structured
mindfulness practice.
Some sort of practice
in which they
are asked to sit and to breathe
and do something that clearly
is not coming from
them, but rather
from us trying to teach them
some tools and skills that
are useful for us.
Is that going against that
principle law of allowing
them to be themselves?
ISA GUCCIARDI: No.
The idea of doing some
kind of a structure
liked a mindfulness practice is
exactly what I'm talking about.
It's a structure that's coming
out of the set of values
that you hold dear.
OK?
So you're going to sit with
your child and say, OK.
This is something
that's important to me.
This is something that I value.
And I'd like to offer it to
you to see what you do with it.
And you know, I don't think that
that's inhibiting the child's
expression in any way.
It's offering, again,
structures that
are based on your values
through which the child can
learn about themselves.
And that's helpful.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
I was wondering about the
idea of the deepest calling.
And to what extent do
you think it's something
that's kind of set at birth?
And to what extent do you
think it might be influenced
by the experiences the child
has maybe before he or she is
able to demonstrate affinity for
any particular sort of thing?
ISA GUCCIARDI: Sorry.
What?
AUDIENCE: Maybe like
um-- to what extent
do you think that that
might be influenced
by the experiences the child has
before he or she is old enough
to be able to show an affinity
for certain types of things
or people or experiences?
I guess part of my question
is how young do you
see this calling in children?
ISA GUCCIARDI: I see It from
almost the moment they're born.
Yeah.
And there are lots
of experiences
that children can have.
You're asking, is this is
something that's in them?
Or is it something
that comes forward
as they mature and have external
environmental influences
on them?
The question of nature
versus nurture, right?
Again, so here's my opinion, OK.
So I actually firmly,
totally, and completely
believe-- OK,
there's an opinion--
that everyone has something in
them that calls them to life.
And different people have
different experiences
that either help them
fulfill that calling,
or they have experiences
where their experience of life
is a thwarting of that calling.
But the calling is
there either way.
And it depends.
I mean, one of the
great tragedies
that I see every day is how
many people have so much beauty
in them that they can't express
because of their wounding
or their pain, right?
And of course, we have all
kinds of ways and depth hypnosis
of resolving that pain,
changing that pain,
changing the relationship
to that pain,
relieving the potential,
releasing the calling.
I mean, that's what
I do all day long.
So I feel like my opinion
is somewhat informed here.
It may be anecdotal.
But I can give you lots of
data of people who feel better
being able to release
their sense of calling
into the world.
Everyone feels better
when they do that.
There's some back there.
That's OK.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
about resources
that I guess-- at
your organization,
you teach about resources to
use to call on during parenting.
Resources to call
on during parenting.
And I was just wondering if you
could maybe mention some things
about resources that-- I guess
you mean like at the exact time
that some issue's coming up.
I've heard that term before.
And I was just
wondering what you're--
ISA GUCCIARDI: What
I'm referring to
with those resources
is that we spend
some time doing some inner
guided meditation to help
connect with aspects
of our self that
actually do know how to parent.
Or have some wisdom
that we don't normally
tap into, because we're
trying to get the milk ready
and like get the
bus driver to wait.
And, you know.
And I think that this is one
of the values of meditation
is to help you be
able to look inward.
But the guided
meditations that we
do are quite focused
in connecting
with an aspect of
yourself that might
take the form of a light or a
sound or a person or an animal.
It may take some form that
is kind of a ray-ified aspect
of this wisdom within yourself.
So that you can
call upon it when
you're ready to
tear your hair out
because your kid won't
get their shoes on.
And it's time to go to school.
And you're going to be late for
that meeting with your boss.
Right?
Where you can just
develop a relationship
with this part of yourself
in a more ray-ified way
so that you can
connect with that
and work with that as
you're deciding what
you're going to do about
putting the shoes on.
Right?
It kind of slows
everything down.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ISA GUCCIARDI: OK
AUDIENCE: Thanks a
lot for your talk.
I particularly
appreciate your focus
on really helping the
kid discover themselves.
And I noticed you talked also
about some structures that
help them learn emotional
intelligence skills,
be more whole,
that sort of thing.
But I feel like as a
parent you are bombarded
with all these structures
that people suggest,
or that society
holds as a standard.
And so you very quickly
get into this situation
where you have to
choose those structures.
And in so doing, you make
decisions based on your values,
assuming that they will
be their values, right?
The business school
example, for instance.
I feel like some parents
would look at that position
as, well, you can't have a
comfortable living if you're
a musician, right?
So make sure you have-- so
that's-- and you don't know
whether your kid is going to
replicate that by you or not.
Right?
And then there are structures
that seem kind of arbitrary,
like anything from table
manners to learning
how to spell correctly.
So you have to make
lots of decisions
your kid before you know or
they know how they would choose.
And so I wonder how
you approach that.
ISA GUCCIARDI: Well,
as I mentioned--
it's a great question.
As I mentioned,
one of the things
that I think is most
helpful to focus on,
especially when kids
are little, is what do I
need to do to keep them safe?
And what do I need to
do to keep them happy?
And that doesn't mean giving
them all the candy they want.
It doesn't mean putting
them on a leash.
So especially when
they're little,
those are two things that you
can always focus on if you're
trying to make a decision.
What do I think about
this computer game?
OK.
Is this going to keep
my kid feeling safe?
Or is the violence in that game
going to give them nightmares?
OK.
I guess I'm not going to give
them that computer game, right?
But if you think about safety
and happiness, and then
you just use that as a measure
as you're holding it up
against all of the
bombardment, as you say,
of the cultural environment.
I have to say as a parent, I
felt like my main primary duty
became filtering the culture.
It was so important because
there's so much in the culture.
I mean, I have a degree
in cultural anthropology.
So I'm already looking
at culture, right?
But there's so much in the
culture that is deadening.
And you have to decide--
again, that's my opinion.
Right?
And you have to
decide, to what extent
do I want my child to
be influenced by that?
And the way you answer
that is, is this
going to keep my
child happy and safe?
Right?
I find that that is a really--
if you don't take anything
else away from this
talk-- just think, mantra.
What will keep my
child happy and safe?
And you may have different
ideas than other people.
But you know you're
doing your best.
Again, I don't think
there's one answer.
Because I think there
are general answers.
But every child has
their own tolerances.
And every parent has
their own set of values.
So again, you have to
have enough structure
to allow for a
range of expression,
not so much structure
that you crush it.
And those two questions--
what will keep my child safe.
And what will keep
my child happy.
Navigate those two
poles pretty well.
Hopefully that's helpful.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ISA GUCCIARDI: Yeah.
RUCHIKA: And Isa will
be around even after
if you want to [INAUDIBLE].
Give opportunity
for the live stream.
One person emailed--
ISA GUCCIARDI:
Ruchika, I'm sorry.
I don't think that's on.
So in case-- Is it?
RUCHIKA: OK.
I'll come closer to you, Isa.
So you can hear me.
So Kendall would
love to know what's
your opinion on CDC announcing
that they're coming to Palo
Alto plus Silicon Valley to
study our mass teen suicides
that you may have
heard of occurring
in Palo Alto in particular.
And why do you
think that might be?
She has her own hypothesis
because she lives here,
but is interested in
knowing what could
be causing the teen suicides.
ISA GUCCIARDI: The question
is, from the live stream,
what do I think might
be causing the surge
in teen suicides in Palo Alto.
Well, the first
thing I always say
is that every case is
completely individual.
It's very difficult to
make generalizations
about any form of behavior.
I would say that this is a very
difficult time to be alive.
I would say that our
children at a very young age
are dealing with the specter
of environmental destruction.
There's a great sorrow in that.
I also think it's very hard
to be young and realizing
that this is what's happening.
It's hard enough for us since
we're older to confront it.
But I think that
also there is a lot
of violence in this culture.
I know that's my opinion.
But there is a lot of
violence in this culture.
And when you have
a lot of violence
that is tolerated,
like on TV shows
and cartoons and
video games, when
you have a lot of violence
that is witnessed and seen
in all the different media
places where children are
seeing it, it's
not too far a step
to think about that violence
being turned inward.
It's like there's a tolerance
of violence in the culture
generally that I personally
think is not healthy.
So the idea of
self-destruction is not
too far away from the
kind of destruction
that they're seeing all
around them all the time.
Now, I think that every
one of those children--
like I would really
like to sit down
with every one of
those children.
I would have loved
the opportunity
to sit down, because there
is this phenomenon that
is occurring.
And this is something
that Jinpa spoke to.
And it's something that I
speak to all the time, which
is this split within the self
that arises in the West, which
is a form of self-loathing.
And it's a disease that
we have here in the West
that doesn't seem to exist
so much in other places,
although everyone
else is catching it.
But this inner division of
the rejection of the self.
And Jinpa tells a
story about this.
Well, I actually-- before I got
to know Jinpa as well as I do,
I used to tell this story,
because I heard this interview
that he gave on "Fresh
Air" in the '90s, when
Terry Gross asked him what is
the most difficult thing you've
ever had to translate
for His Holiness?
And he said that he was in
an East/West conference.
And he translated the word
self-loathing into Tibetan.
And His Holiness stopped
him and said, no, no, no no.
You must be doing that wrong.
That's the wrong translation.
And Jinpa said, no.
That's the translation.
It's self-loathing.
And His Holiness said, but the
self cannot loathe the self.
So I mean, one of the most
erudite people on the planet
did not understand that we
do have this disease here
in the West, the self-loathing,
the self-- and this
is one of the primary
things that I work with.
I have a new book coming out
called "Coming to Peace."
And it's about the
reflection of inner violence
in outer relationships,
and the way
that our outer relationship
express or give us information
about our own inner violence.
Other inner experience as well.
But it's a book about
conflict resolution,
basically saying that we
cannot have peace in external
relationships until we
have peace in the internal
relationship with ourself.
And I think that there is this
idea, this scientific idea--
what is this self?
This is not scientific.
We can't prove it.
You know, what is this?
And there's rejection of spirit,
this rejection of the soul,
this rejection of the
deeper part of the self,
which is extremely
unscientific to just reject
this aspect of experience.
And so people don't
have tools, they
don't have vocabulary
to speak to this kind
of inner dislocation
that they experience,
because there's nothing
rational or replicable about it.
And yet, people suffer deeply
internally because they cannot
rest in themselves.
And one of the reasons they
cannot rest in themselves is
because they look around them.
There's so much violence.
There's no place
to rest externally.
They go inside themselves.
They haven't been able
to develop resources
because everyone says there's
no such thing as spirit,
there's no such thing as
soul, there's no such thing
as the deeper self.
And so they're left
with this emptiness.
Right?
So there's my attempt
to answer that question.
And I would imagine
that most of those teens
were walking somewhere along
in this field of experience
that I've just described here.
RUCHIKA: Thank you,
Isa for coming down
today and answering
our questions
and sharing your wisdom.
Isa will be here for lunch.
So if you want to join us or
ask questions if some of them
were not answered,
please come up.
And join the
mindful-parenting group.
Right now I'm announcing
it to GPause [INAUDIBLE]
on Parents Network.
But I'm sure not everybody is
a parent or interested in it.
So we'll start communicating
to mindful-dash parenting group
more about these
conversations and talks.
So if you have passion for
this field, just write to me.
And we can organize events and
classes here together as well.
So thank you for coming.
And thanks to everyone who
joined our live stream as well.
And we'll look forward
to seeing you soon.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]